welcome back to cbs mornings we have
more now on the investigation into the
subway shooting here in new york city
that injured at least 23 people
witnesses say a man wearing a gas mask
and construction vest opened fire at
commuters after throwing a smoke grenade
inside a subway car during the morning
rush hour he was on the train as well 10
of the injured people were shot the
suspect is still on the run at this hour
though police have named a person of
interest they are looking for in
connection with the investigation no
pictures so far as cameras at the
station where the shooting happened were
not working at the time
joining us is jano lieber chairman and
ceo of the mta which runs new york
city's subway systems jano good morning
thank you for being here tough morning
after for new yorkers today a lot of
people probably thinking twice before
their regular commute
one of the big questions to come out of
this is why don't we have a picture of
this gunman why weren't the cameras
working well actually they do have
photos and the material that the nypd
has circulated has a variety of
different images of him so
all night long we have 600 cameras on
this one line in brooklyn um 2500
cameras the length of the line so the
cops have been looking overnight at all
of the stations where he got on where he
might have gotten off there's an
enormous range of video it's one of the
things we've done to make the system
safer we went from 30 camera coverage
of our 472 stations to 100 camera
coverage so we had a lot of video for
the cops to look at and they're working
but how do you explain that on this
particular train the cameras do not
appear to be working was that just a
fluke yeah i think that i think that in
the one location by the turnstile there
there was apparently a server problem
which they had been working on the day
before but the bigger issue is there's
so much video evidence from all of the
stations on this line that there there
are images of this fellow that are going
to be found we heard that the mayor said
that they're now going to double the
number of police on patrol but would
that have prevented this from happening
jano don't you actually need officers on
the train good it's a very good point
gail i've been asking for you know since
the prior mayoral administration i've
been asking for can we get the cops
there are a lot of cops in the system
but we want them on the trains and on
the platforms where new yorkers feel
like federal marshals on a plane well
you know exactly the
where people feel we know from surveying
our riders and we survey a hundred
thousand riders every month or so
cops on platforms cops on trains that is
what makes people feel safe the mayor
has committed to do that that transition
has already been underway since before
this incident but if you have a random
person doing a random thing it's going
to be hard to stop even if you do have
police which raises the question did the
mta in any way know who this individual
was have him under monitoring and have
any idea this morning why he chose such
a a far-flung and seemingly random
station honestly tony we we don't have
any history with this guy the nypd he
has a bunch of priors from what i
understand uh so he has some history
with law enforcement uh in general but
we don't have any history with him at
the mta and there's no reason we would
have focused on him in particular new
yorkers feel safe taking the train today
you know i think they were looking as i
said when i got on the train with the
governor the train was full new yorkers
really we're in the um never bet against
new york business it's the essence of
who we are bounce back after 9 11. i
spent a lot of years rebuilding the
world trade center people said you
wouldn't they wouldn't move back to
lower manhattan after 9 11. people said
new york was dead after superstorm sandy
and on and on and on new yorkers just
keep bouncing back and the subway is the
fabric of new york nobody's going to
give up our public space that defines
new york that makes new york possible
that's what the subway is the heroic mta
workers who powered those people out of
the station to safety are also heroes
good qualities of new york were on
evidence yesterday as well
and sort of new york may be down but
never out you're never out here always
not even close i'm also on the bed on
new york business so yeah thank you very
much general libra appreciate it with
you good to be with you